[Applaudissements]
mais non c impossible voilà la radio
cibl c'est depuis des années mais bon
vous connaissez mal non la fa la radio
si j'aime et j'ai pas de dons je suis
rarement vu en calcul mental mais sinon
c'est une immonde arnaque non pas
d'oreillette j'ai regardé la can u et là
que j'ai fait à syrie depuis un peu plus
de deux ans alors ça a commencé à europe
1 c'est vrai et depuis ça continue à
touche pas à mon poste
le baht alors il était simple faire des
calculs très compliqué sans oreillette
pour pas se faire gauler alors bien sûr
vous allez me dire il faut quand même
avoir une bonne mémoire et pas se
tromper dans les chiffres
il suffit d'être malin 2406 2406 c'est
la bonne réponse ne compte qu'un café de
2005 4 06 29 10 et 20 05 ce qui
correspond à l'anniversaire de mon fils
de ma fille et de ma soeur dans le culte
tunisien je cuisine très très mal fait
très très bien m
c'est pas vrai mais chanter que ça vous
ferait plaisir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on parle on
la bouche allez allez gillou la bouche
quand plaisir ça va pas autant ça sera
moins dur c'est sûr ça va être dur du
tout une fois la bouche chef fe pattani
j'aurai les jambes
[Applaudissements]
je tiens qu'est ce qui s'passe gène muté
et ça